we realize at this moment that our
nation has heard our plea for help here
in New York City and there could not be
a better example of all of America
pulling for New York City than the
arrival of the USNS comfort some major
major moment in this long battle that we
will be fighting against the coronavirus
I think there have been times in recent
days where loud New Yorkers have felt
alone live New Yorkers have felt a sense
of not being sure what's coming next not
being sure of help would come well I
want to say to all New Yorkers we have
evidence here you are not alone we are
not alone our nation is helping us in
our hour of need
there's a lot of people to thank and
you're going to hear from two of our
real heroes here from the federal
government who are doing so much for us
you're gonna hear from Rear Admiral John
must in a moment in the Regional
Administrator for FEMA Tom Van Essen
who's well known to all of us in New
York City but I want to thank everyone
who was a part of this many many people
work together and look we got to
remember this is a wartime atmosphere we
all have to pull together we may have
differences in peacetime but to the
maximum extent possible we all have to
be as one in wartime I know our
colleagues in the military understand
that we all need to understand that now
so I do want to thank the President
Trump I want to thank secretary Esper I
want to thank chairman milli
everyone at the United States Navy the
United States Marine Corps the United
States Coast Guard all the people at
FEMA so many people the federal
government who came together to make
this happen and so much more for New
York City I want to thank Governor Cuomo
and everyone in the state government who
has joined us in pushing from day one
for this kind of support
I want to thank from our administration
everyone who worked to get the dredging
done working with the military I want
everyone to understand and Admiral mustn
will affirm this this ship is here ahead
of schedule because the amazing work of
the military it's here ahead of schedule
because the dredging was done faster
than anyone knew it could be done to
allow this ship to dock I want to thank
everyone in the City Economic
Development Corporation our Emergency
Management team and also of course the
State Department environmental
conservation and the Army Corps
engineers everyone pulled together this
was supposed to take two weeks to make
it possible for this ship to dock they
did it in eight days and that means help
has arrived quicker and we're going to
be able to do the life-saving work right
now I want to also thank from the
military one of the leaders who did the
work to make this moment possible Marine
Corps colonel brian de Plessis who's
with us Thank You colonel and from my
team deputy mayor Raoul parea gente for
Health and Human Services and
Commissioner James Hendon Department of
Veterans Services Colonel James Hendon
thank you
so with this ship comes an extraordinary
complement of talented individuals and
service to our nation 1200 medical staff
and sailors here to help us all 750 beds
will be put into play immediately to
relieve the pressure on a hospital
system let me be clear that this is such
a crucial part of the plan we are
putting in place but I want to
understand the sheer magnitude of the
plan we need to triple our hospital bed
capacity in New York City by May the
number of beds we had a beginning of
March have to triple by May is a
daunting task but we got a big big boost
the arrival the comfort this is like
adding a whole nother hospital to New
York City it's like think of all the big
hospitals in New York City Bellevue and
all the other famous hospitals we think
of it's like another one of them just
floated right up to help us right now
and I hope New Yorkers know that this is
something we've been fighting for him
we're gonna be fighting for a lot more
help because this is just the beginning
my job is always to tell you the truth
and I'll tell you when we get the help
we need and I'll tell you when we need
more help I'll tell you when we're
getting into the thick of the battle and
I'll tell you when we're coming out of
the battle right now the toughest weeks
are still ahead but we are grateful we
are grateful for every doctor for every
nurse for every ventilator for the
supplies for the beds for everything
that's come from the Comfort and
everything that has come from all over
the country I have to tell you it's the
federal government it's the state
government of course but it's also the
companies that have come forward
offering help people we've never met
individuals who come forward with
supplies health care workers who have
volunteered it's the United Nations
which came up with a quarter million
surgical masks and got them to us right
away we're seeing amazing offers of help
and people are moving fast to get help
to New York City and we appreciate it we
need it
so let's look forward let's pray there's
to be a lot more days like this when
people can see our nation's stand by us
and then I affirm to you when the battle
is done here New York City will stand
firm for the rest of our nation New York
City will be the first to donate to the
rest of our nation we will send the
ventilators the supplies we will ask our
doctors and nurses to go to the front
wherever it is in this nation because
our country was there for us and we will
be there for our country a few words in
Spanish
este barkow es un symbol or para los
ninos no estamos solos en esta lucha
haremos todo lo posible para tener la
capacidad que necesitamos ultra cidades
Estados vamos a estar allí para ustedes
como usted es en estado IE para nosotros
without if i want to turn to a guy who's
been a hero before for this city and we
need him to be a hero again and I know
he is already rising to the occasion he
helped lead New York City through our
darkest hour on 9/11
he was then our fire commissioner and he
did an outstanding job under the most
adverse circumstances our fire
department had ever known when he became
the Regional Administrator for FEMA he
could never have imagined this day nor
could any of us but I said to Tom
earlier thank God he is where he is now
I think God had a plan for him because
his city needs him again my great honor
to introduce the Regional Administrator
for FEMA
tom Van Essen von Essen my apologies I
kind of fan that
Thank You mayor yeah it's
it's it's really seems I've gotten real
personal for me this morning about two
weeks ago we moved to our regional
response recovery coordination team down
to a Naval Base in Earl New Jersey where
we have an operation center and we were
able to get people off public
transportation we have all our equipment
down there or set up there it's really
good set up it was built during sandy at
a naval base so we have about 3035
people working there every day late late
into the night working to try and
accommodate everybody we can in New York
City New York State New Jersey Puerto
Rico and the Virgin Islands that's what
region two is at FEMA so I've been down
there the last two weeks and I came back
for this today and I was driving on East
River Drive and I looked across by 14th
Street and I had a flashback to the
morning I was driving in and and they
told me a small plane had crashed into
the Trade Center and life changed at
that time and I remember having a
comfort come then you know a couple I
don't remember when a couple weeks late
or whatever and we didn't need it for
what we needed for today we didn't need
it for people who needed hospital care
it wasn't necessary but we brought it in
we needed it for crisis counseling for a
lot of fire chiefs and police officers
who were really really overcome with the
grief and a debt that they faced with
their friends and people that they
worked with and we needed it to house
federal workers and give them food and
everything and we got it out of here and
we stopped putting them in hotel rooms
but I'll never forget that feeling and I
talked about it this morning the names
are perfect the comfort and the mercy I
was told they were here in 1918 for the
pandemic we had then not these
particular ships but their predecessors
so the federal government has always
been here the army the Navy the Marines
that they've always been here for us
when we
them and they here again for you now and
for me to the flashbacks I get knowing
that the city is under such stress now
it's it's real personal for me the fire
department I spent 30 years in it so
when September 11th happened it was
personal it was friends it was leaders
people who had worked with everybody was
affected by September 11th and that's
what's happening now everybody you know
is affected by the corona virus in one
way or another a friend the relative a
loved one that you can't go and see
because they're in quarantine or you
don't want to I mean I stopped to see a
hundred-year-old lady last week and just
you know talk to her from 6 feet away
and I know everybody's doing that and
it's important but this this is a big
time visible sign of what our government
is like when we put it into action and
the mayor said it and it's really I'm
really proud to be part of it now I know
how tough the people of this city are
and I've seen us take on some seemingly
insurmountable insurmountable challenges
once again we need to do it once again
we need to be together 6 feet apart I
saw the mayor taking pictures with some
of the military folks I never noticed it
before taking a picture with someone it
was 2 or 3 feet away it's weird it's
really strange what we're all going
through but it's necessary and it is
going to make a difference the more we
separate the more everybody stays away
the better off we'll be in the faster
we'll get out of this but thank goodness
now help is arrived that's going to make
a big difference
FEMA is working with the city with the
state to supply everything we possibly
can working with HHS to get as many
medical people here as we can people
help us with the forensics and the
mortuary problems that we're going to
have because we are going to have an
awful lot of folks that aren't going to
make it but we're doing the best we can
and it's a it's an honor to be back in
the middle of
of of such a such a tough tough battle
that we have in front of us with
September 11th it seemed like every day
we were fixing stuff and it was getting
a slightly better the grief of course
was was enormous but the operation
seemed to get slightly better every day
with this it seems to be we're not there
yet it's not gonna get better might not
get better for us here in the city for
weeks maybe a month I hope not
I don't know I listened to dr. Fauci on
here about models and worst-case
scenarios best case scenarios we just
don't know so we are preparing for the
worst case and that's all we can do at
this point and we're doing a good job
and we're here for you thank you
thank you so much Tom now of such an
honor to bring to you the military
leader of this effort he comes from a
family long connected to the US Navy he
is someone we're thinking about right
now as one of our saviors one of the
people who led the forces that came to
help us in our hour of need but his day
job
his vice commander of u.s. fleet forces
so he has a big big job and a lot to
think about but right now his mind his
heart his soul is focused on New York
City and I'm proud to say he is also a
resident of Manhattan it has a family
here and understands what we are all
going through and I just want to express
on behalf of 8.6 million New Yorkers my
gratitude for your leadership and for
all the men and women who serve under
your command an honor to present to you
Rear Admiral John Mustan
mr. mayor mr. administrator commissioner
thank you for being here today to
welcome this great ship to the officers
the crew the medical professionals of
USNS comfort thank you for the vital
mission that you've undertaken I'd also
like to recognize and thank the many
many contributors who work tirelessly
behind the scenes to make this day
possible each of those who helped to fit
out and prepare this ship in record time
from the maintenance community to the
dock workers to the ship's company to
the doctors to the dredgers thank you
all of you for the agility and
professionalism that you have all shown
over the past few weeks that focused
collective effort will save American
lives today I also want to recognize
that not all of our nation's heroes wear
military uniforms especially today we
acknowledge that many wear scrubs let us
not forget nor failed to recognize that
the doctors and nurses across America
those who are treating patients in these
unprecedented times they are all heroes
and like those heroes the unmistakable
White Hall and Red Cross of this great
ship have been a welcome sight around
the world standing at the forefront of
our humanitarian missions overseas this
ship ship represents all that is good
about the American people all that is
generous all that is ready responsive
and resolute like her sister ship the
USNS mercy was recently moored and is
already serving patients in Los Angeles
this great ship will support civil
authorities by increasing medical
capacity and collaboration for medical
assistance not treating kovat 19
patients but by acting as a relief valve
for other urgent needs freeing New
York's hospitals and our precious
medical professionals to focus on this
pandemic so now this great ship will
serve and support our fellow Americans
in this time of need
providing critical surge hospital
capacity to America's largest city
as a resident new yorker myself i can
attest to the invincible spirit of new
york from the ships that she built in
world war ii to her unflappable
determination following 9/11 and
hurricane sandy i have great confidence
that new york well whether today's storm
as well this time with the support of
another great american community the
naval families on board and supporting
the crew of the USNS comfort words are
incapable of expressing the depth of my
gratitude for those on this mission and
for the families that they leave behind
the men and women on board comfort our
mothers their fathers their sons
daughters sisters and brothers and while
our lives may look drastically too
different today than they did even a
month ago the circumstances for these
men and women are no exception
they left their families during this
uncertain time in our nation's history
knowing that they can make a difference
that is what the US Navy does and this
is an example of Americans helping their
fellow men I know that for our military
families social distancing is not a new
concept but rather a frequent reality
and I remain grateful for all that each
of them do for our nation and for our
communities every single day as you
heard from the administrator the last
time this great hospital ship all 70,000
tons of herb was in New York was in the
wake of 9/11 where she served as a
respite and comfort for first responders
working around the clock today like then
we bring a message to all New Yorkers
now your navy is returned and we are
with you committed in this fight mr.
mayor every sailor every marine and
every civilian on this mission stands
proudly stands ready to serve the people
of New York City we have not yet begun
to fight and we will not give up this
ship thank you
[Applause]
beautifully said Admiral and thank you
so much all right we're gonna take
questions now from the media and just
please project your voices so I can hear
you well
go ahead even better yes Thank You mr.
mayor so what's your what's your message
to President Trump after the Comfort
docked here to help New York City and
when it came in here to the pier
what was your emotion and what was your
reaction overall it's a very emotional
moment I went up on the roof here to
watch the comfort come in and I had this
incredible feeling of peace actually
that help was finally coming that we
were not alone and I just have a
reverence for the military I come from a
family that had a deep involvement in
the military I have a reverence for the
military feeling the presence of the
United States military here it just gave
me a sense that things were going to be
okay and just as such a moving sight the
ship is so impressive
it just looming there in our harbor you
know was like a beacon of hope and it
really felt that way to me my message to
the president is thank you and we need
more help and that's not because any of
us likes to have to say that but because
it's true that the toughest weeks are
ahead we are bracing ourselves for
something we've never seen before
in any of our lives and and the federal
government in many ways is the only
force that can help us to reach the
level of preparation we need to save
every life we can save so I'm going to
keep calling the president and keep
appealing to him to get us all the help
we need for these really tough weeks and
then again we will turn around and help
everyone else in this country right
after I'll go on this side yes mr. mayor
as you know normally this time of year
we'd be very busy and focused on the
state budget at Albany I just want to
ask I know it's kind of a secondary
issue now but there is a lot getting
crafted up there
do you have any concerns in terms of
what you've been hearing in terms of how
the city will be effective I have real
concerns I have deep concerns because
what's being discussed is essentially
health care for people who need it when
you know we can talk about the Medicaid
budget but that's what I think the wrong
way to think about what it equals is
healthcare for people who need
healthcare right now and need it more
than ever because of the pandemic I
spoke at length last night with speaker
Karl hasty and Majority Leader Andrea
stewart-cousins I let them know that
from the perspective of eight point six
million people in New York City
we cannot afford Medicaid cuts
healthcare cuts at this dire moment the
state must accept the Medicaid funding
that was in the third stimulus bill we
need that money to be accepted and we
need to make sure that the healthcare so
many people are depending on is not
disrupted so I understand that the state
has a budget challenge we have a huge
budget challenge I mean I'm right now in
the middle of cutting a huge amount out
of this budget for this city right now
but what I will not cut is healthcare
and I said that day today we're going to
find some really tough cuts we have to
make but it will never be about
healthcare it will never be about the
fight against kovat 19 so I urge the
state accept the federal money do not
cut Medicaid do not cut health care for
New Yorkers who need it that's good okay
well just keep going back and forth
whoever is at the microphone go ahead
tell us what the what kind of services
the ship will be providing and who how
will it be something decided look
patients will be going to ship in which
patients will stay at the hospital I'm
going to start and I'll let the Admiral
join in obviously what I have to explain
to everyone I think is such a shock to
hear this that people are still kind of
adjusting to it the intensive care units
in our hospitals used to be a small part
of our hospitals and again a beginning
of this month we had about 20,000
working hospital beds in New York City
what we have to do is convert as many as
possible potentially almost all of those
traditional hospital beds into ICU beds
we have to make whole Hospital
into intensive care units to get through
these next week's that's how dire that's
how tough this situation is if we're
going to turn a hospital
I mean think of Bellevue think of NYU
Langone you go by these huge buildings
they're all they're gonna be all ICU if
we can bring all the pieces together the
staff and the equipment and everything
well what happens to everyone else who
doesn't need intensive care we have to
have hospitals for them too what happens
to people who've been infected with
kovat 19 but are not at the point where
they need intensive care hopefully on
the way to recovery they need a hospital
bed in many cases - but we can't put
them in the intensive care unit which
has to be reserved for those we're
trying to save so what the USNS comfort
allows and Javits Center and so many
other places being developed right now
is the ability to take all those other
patients and give them care and each
location will be different but it will
allow us to keep a healthcare system
going while we convert the core
hospitals into something we've never
done and this is beyond anyone's
imagination I asked ahead of our public
hospitals dr. Mitch Katz I said have you
ever heard of any place where they have
to turn hospitals into all ICU he said
no no one's ever come near having to do
that in the last hundred years in this
country but because the comfort is here
because of what's happened at Javits
Center we're gonna have the ability to
do that and save a lot of lives Admiral
you want to join in just in terms of the
specifics and the mechanics we've been
working very closely with the local
healthcare officials to determine what
that process looks like so so frankly we
are prepared to receive and we trust the
screening process that is in effect at
the Javits Center so that we will
receive advance notice so that the ship
can prepare to receive the patients but
but in terms of what the health care
providers determine are the best
patients for us those are the ones that
we would expect to receive
how can you take us to the mechanics of
this transfer of patience
how are you communicate this to the
patient what kind of situations are
these patients experiencing and are the
family is gonna be able to visit them
onboard of their comfort all right I'm
gonna start and I'm gonna give you the
disclaimer right away that all of this
is being worked out in real-time so I
guarantee you we're not going to have
all those questions and all those
answers today because we're literally in
a wartime situation building it as we go
along
dr. Raul Pedroia Henson a deputy mayor
if at any you want to jump in on any of
these questions about procedure please
do or Admiral as well I think the common
sense basic answer is we're going to
work out the protocol between all the
players how to get the right patients to
the right locations again reserving the
hospital's for ICU to the maximum extent
Hospital max looks impossible some
places will specialize in convalescent
Cova 19 patients meaning patients on the
way to recovery no longer intensive care
some places will specialize in all sorts
of other medical needs that require
hospitalization because remember all the
folks with heart disease all the folks
would cancer there's still so many
people that will need hospitalization
for other things that are not kovat 19
so we're working out those protocols
right now as to things like visitation I
think a fair statement would be the
normal rules will not apply it's going
to on the non doctor telling all New
Yorkers right now we're going to always
try to respect families but we have to
be clear that the normal rules of going
to a hospital just aren't going to exist
in this kind of wartime environment and
people should get used to a different
set of standards it will be determined
for each location what that is
but there's going to be such urgency
dealing with a huge uptick in cases that
we can't do all the things we normally
do Admiral you want to add or deputy
okay never mayor
yes as the mayor outlined we have stood
up Hospital Executive Committee which
includes all the public hospitals the
voluntary hospitals the independent
hospitals in the command from Comfort
Inn Javits there's a screening mechanism
very complex in order to allocate who
goes where as the mayor pointed out we
are prepared to convert as many of the
regular beds in all hospitals in the
city into ICU beds hopefully we'll get
the ventilators so the most severe cases
end up being taken care of there the
visitation piece will require a
screening like we're doing for everyone
right now so if there is any risk that a
patient that has no kovat 19 that is
being taken care of here the comfort has
a relative that could be potentially
infected of course there will be
screening for them not to come in
we had said that Saturday you would
decide whether or not to close the
playgrounds why have you left the
playgrounds open when for example
Hoboken has closed its parks in Bergen
County has closed its parks why do we
not have consistency on that guideline
for social distancing this is an issue
that obviously we're working with the
state on and the states have all been
working together and there is not one
uniform standard that's just the truth
we are very cognizant look eight point
six million people in a very small space
I don't think taking away parks is a
great idea unless we have evidence that
people are not following the rules in a
really substantial way I have had this
conversation daily with our police
commissioner
he says overwhelmingly they are seeing
compliance we know warmer weather is
coming not today but warmer weather is
coming we're gonna watch carefully what
I said yesterday is this right now the
police and all our agencies are
authorized to use fines we've given
enough warning enough education anyone
who if you Andrew we're in the park and
officer said sir you're not practicing
social distancing I need to move and you
said I'm not going to move they're gonna
say sir you're about to be given a fine
this is your last chance and if you
don't move or you don't follow the
instruction you've gotta find if we see
any basketball courts where there's
games going on and we've warned people
to stop we're going to take down the
rims we're going to take out tennis nets
we're going to take out soccer net
whatever it takes on the playgrounds we
see individual playgrounds where there's
non-compliance we can close the
playground if we see it broadly all the
playgrounds will be closed but to date
based on the sheer facts coming back
from the police department Parks
Department non-compliance is limited you
will find some instances I'm sure you
will Andrew but not enough to tell eight
point six million people they cannot
have parks and that's the balance we're
trying to strike
Thank You mr. mayor yesterday we heard
the British carrying numbers from the
federal government do you have any
particular forecasting scenario for
decision I mean the particular for New
York City
I've been real honest with New Yorkers
at this point we assume at least half of
all New Yorkers will contract this
disease again consistently we see for 80
percent that means thankfully a fairly
mild experience that they get through
okay recover quickly but right now at
least 50% it could be substantially more
we see this horrible increase in the
number of deaths and I've been honest I
think the weeks ahead will be tougher to
date I still fear that the worst is not
going to be April but actually the
beginning of May but no projection is
perfect I guarantee you and I wish I'd
couldn't but I guarantee you that
April is going to be exceedingly tough
and we have to understand that any
projection of things being all okay by
Easter there's just no way that's true
for New York City
this is a question extra for the former
fire commissioner von Essen High
Commissioner can I ask you a quiet
over here
hey welcome back to New York thank you I
never left well great to have you here
now
I'm wondering you mentioned mortuary
logistics what are you working on right
now what's the current city capacity to
hold the deceased and is there any
consideration of turning places like MSG
Madison Square Garden into a mortuary
facility no fortunately we not thinking
of anything like that but we are sending
refrigeration trucks to New York to help
with some of the problem on a temporary
basis I was speaking to Commissioner
Chris well this morning we've sent the
military has sent 42 folks to the
Manhattan medical examiner's office to
help over there and we need you have a
desk New York City has we in New York
City have a desperate need to help over
in Queens and we're working on that as
we speak there's folks trying to put it
all together there's only so many of
these teams that the military has we
have 50 states in a couple of
territories and Commonwealth's that
we're trying to not hold back resources
but trying to make it make a plan ready
that works for the whole country so it's
it's it's difficult but everybody's
trying and we will get more help here
for New York thank you Mary this is a
very visual representation of the help
that's arrived but can you give us a
clearer sense of how much more help is
going to be needed if you will how many
equivalents of the Comfort does New York
City need to get through the worst of
this sir yeah it's a great great way of
thinking about it
think of this ship which is 750 beds to
begin as a capacity potentially of a
thousand beds so here's the way to think
of what we're all working on right now
we started with around 20,000 working
beds in New York City we have to get
over 60,000 by the beginning of May
according to what we know now like
adding 40 us comforts I mean that's the
magnitude of what we're talking about
and the amazing thing is that we believe
with enough people working together that
we can get there as hard as that sounds
you know here's this extraordinary
contribution from the federal government
here's a Javits Center we're talking
about up to 3,000 beds right there the
surge capacity in the hospitals where
every hospital is adding 50% more beds
that's on top of that original 20,000
they're all finding additional beds to
add in their facilities you know
creating new spaces Mitch Katz said a
long time ago he can turn the cafeteria
into an ICU if he needs to he can put up
a tent in the parking lot turn into ICU
and then the hotels and the other
buildings that we'll be moving to so
it's our human task it's never been
attempted in the history of New York
City we believe that's the number we'd
love to find out it's a lesser number
but that's the number we're shooting for
and I believe with enough work enough
creativity enough teamwork we can get to
it last night your administration made
an announcement about all of the
supplies and the ventilators you've
given to the pub to the hospitals
throughout the cities
I'm wondering how your administration is
handling supply distribution to private
hospitals a lot of it has been focused
on going to the public hospitals
rightfully so but I'm wondering if any
of these supplies and ventilators have
gone to the private hospitals on Staten
Island yes absolutely and I've had this
conversation daily with borough
president otto to make sure that
supplies are getting where they're
needed yes
the city has provided supplies to Rumsey
and in substantial numbers and will
continue to do so the supplies for
Staten Island University Hospital come
from a combination of sources state city
north well the north wall hospital
system but I'm keeping an eye I and my
team is on all of it we really don't see
a separation between public hospitals
voluntaries independence in this kind of
situation we're all working together
remember the other day we got in 400
ventilators from the federal government
we sent a hundred to the public
hospitals three hundreds of the
voluntaries and independence so that's
going to be the pattern not necessarily
that percentage but that approach we're
all sharing to make sure at any given
moment a hospital has what it needs go
ahead how are you guys planning to get
go ahead go bid patients from the outer
boroughs to the comfort places like
Staten Island again the idea the idea is
to keep folks who need that urgent care
that ICU care in hospitals that will be
converted increasingly to ICU care folks
who do not require ICU care but do need
hospitalization for Cova at 19 the goal
is to keep them as close as possible of
course to their home and in their home
borough so we're continuing to build out
capacity in Staten Island and we will
continue as in every borough
can you hear me yeah with rent due
tomorrow for many people I wanted to ask
about our proposal from some local
officials who want to allow people to
apply their security deposits to next
month's rent do you support that are you
doing anything to make that a reality
I do support that and I think the my
understanding is that we need some kind
of state action to allow that to happen
but I think that's exactly the right
approach look everyone's hand-to-mouth
or so many people at least are
hand-to-mouth right now their income has
just been blown away federal help is
coming but that will take time people
need help right now
applying the security deposits actually
it helps the renter to pay the rent it
actually helps in many cases landlords
especially smaller landlords because
that money is in escrow right now and
the smaller landlords need money to get
by as well so it frees them up for them
there has to be some process to
eventually restore that deposit you know
over time maybe an installment plan over
time but immediate relief is needed so I
think it's a great idea we're working
with folks at the state level to see how
to make that happen okay go ahead mr.
mayor in terms of you've talked about
the ventilators in the hospital beds
where you at in terms of the PPE for the
hospital workers nurses doctors where
where we stand on so on on personal
protective equipment this week and I'm
always giving you this update week by
week if it ever turns into needing to
tell you day by day I will this week in
terms of personal protective equipment
for our hospitals we do have a
sufficient supply we have sent it out
and continue to send it out around the
city hospitals is something dr. Katz
said yesterday everyone has to keep in
mind
hospitals are teaching their
professionals their health care workers
a new way of handling this equipment
because until there is a truly ample
supply like there used to be in
peacetime folks are being trained to
handle the supply differently to stretch
it out to reuse it whenever safe that's
a whole different way of life
and instead of seeing in the supply
closet you know a month or two supply
people are seeing less they're seeing
days or a few weeks and I think is
understandably unnerving to the
healthcare professionals but we're all
working together to help there to
understand a new reality for this moment
in history the supply today is
sufficient it will take us into next
week the thing I'm worried about right
now is ventilators overwhelmingly I've
asked the president the White House or
400 more we will take them from any
source if four hundred more come in some
other way that's great but we need that
to make sure we will get to April 5th
okay
as we approach April 5th which I've said
is a very day I'm really concerned about
in terms of equipment and in terms of
personnel I will update New Yorkers as
to whether we have enough to get through
the next week but that's how tight it
has been number one concerned
ventilators right behind it the need for
more doctors nurses respiratory
therapists to actually handle ICU
capacity and give some relief to these
health workers who have gone through so
much yeah go ahead said 1.3 billion
dollars you were looking to cut from the
budget but then that number it might
need to update it will go up we'll give
you an updated number shortly but it's
definitely gonna go up Thank You mr.
mayor
and we'll patients treated on the
Comfort have to pay their medical bills
as usual or will this be paid for by the
federal government well I don't know
Admiral I mean first of all insurance is
insurance so whoever has insurance I
assume that's the go-to but Admiral or
role do you know the answer day when it
doesn't
yes sir when the president declared a
national emergency the implication from
the Department of Defense is that we
provide this service and we are not
looking to check insurance cards or or
send any invoices or bills that this is
an investment by the government on
behalf of the people of America so there
is no additional cost of the patient
Admiral that's a great plan we thank you
for that Thank You mr. mayor
you mentioned that 750 beds are
available immediately on the Comfort
does that mean that patients will start
being moved today and if so or if not
how many patients will be moved in what
sort of time frame I want to make sure
they're fully docked before any patients
and they're still there still securing
it but between the Admiral and deputy
mayor who wants to speak about the
timelines you want to start early so as
the mayor mentioned well obviously we
want to take care of all of the regular
husbanding services required once the
ship comes into port we're prepared to
begin receiving patients tomorrow I
won't open the box to say while we may
be ready internally to do that sooner we
want to use a very methodical process
that's been developed in conjunction
with the local health authorities which
is predicated on starting tomorrow so a
quick point we're gonna do that the
assessment that I talked about before
with the hospital committee going
through the Javits Center and as the
patient's tarkanian coming from the
hospitals screening will happen today in
probably in the next day or two you'll
start seeing patients here Thank You mr.
mayor did you get any results any
outcomes of the drug test which was
started last week wait which one I'm
sorry clarify I mean last Wednesday you
were supposed to tell to start the drug
test of the new kind of medications
regarding this problem yeah there's
several different approaches that are
being tested now in certainly in our
public health system but I want to make
sure we give you a fully accurate answer
so I'm not updated on that I'll make
sure our team from Health and Hospitals
get you that answer okay everybody thank
you very much good day for New York City
thank you everyone